Drive by day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Last couple of years you've been,
you been involved in a lot of crazy
shit,
you know,
what are you,
have you,
are you disappointed in yourself with a
lot of this stuff?
I told him I totally,
um,
what does it feel like?
Like,
like,
like gimme the thought.
Like we can go through all of them,
but give me the thought like probably
the most,
I was disappointed in you and I love you
as a person.
I think you're a great guy.
Oh,
you too,
Joe.
Thanks.
I really do.
I've always had a good time hanging out
with you,
but I was very disappointed with you
with that car accident.
Then when you ran away from that car
accident,
that to me was like,
God damn John's in a bad place.
Yeah,
it was.
It was,
I was at a bad place.
It was a,
it was a messed up situation,
man.
I literally,
I was an important mental life then when
I was winning all these fights,
I was the boy in the UFC.
I'm sponsored by Nike and gator aid and
greatest of all time finishing legends
after legend after legend.
I'm just really in this position where I
felt so untouchable and I just felt like
I just felt like everything was meant to
go my way.
And that that time of my life,
um,
started to,
I was obviously,
I was smoking pot,
you know,
majority of my career,
dre man,
too shy,
drank and you know,
every weekend pretty much,
you know,
to the point of blacking out,
just locking out.
Yeah.
Just,
just be at the hammer,
you know,
and just being a total party boy.
But still,
I'm still training my butt off,
you know,
I'm working really hard,
believing really hard,
had big goals,
big dreams,
but just being a party boy.
And I think I just took everything that
I have for granted because everything
for the majority of my career has come
my way.
And um,
that that morning I got in a car
accident,
man.
I just,
it was,
it was just,
it was a huge reality check and it was,
you know,
I think in some people's mind they,
they envisioned me,
you know,
hitting this car and running up and
seeing that it was a pregnant lady and
then take it off Vernon.
And then people said that I came back
and grabbed a load of money,
which is the stupidest thing ever.
Why would a millionaire and need to grab
cash,
right.
Unless there's one back to the car.
So I literally,
I went through a light,
um,
it was like a green light that says that
I could turn left,
but he was supposed to yield for the
right away,
right to turn left.
And um,
um,
person came through and I,
I just assumed it was my green light to
go,
obviously being,
um,
not completely clear headed.
And I ended up running into a car.
Um,
I was definitely disoriented.
I'm disoriented from the accident,
from the accident for sure.
Just kind of like what the hell just
happened.
It was a really big hit.
Um,
but that was fine.
I had no injuries and I just felt like,
well maybe it wasn't that bad of a hit.
So I literally,
um,
a step out of the car and I realized
like seconds later and I realized my
bulls in the car.
So your bowl?
My Ball,
my,
yeah,
my pop bought pot.
Yeah.
And I wasn't smoking weed in the car or
anything,
but it was in the car.
But my bowl that had residue was in the
car.
So I literally,
I opened my car door,
I'd like to take two steps away from the
car and then I go back to the car and I,
I like search the car cause I had it in
my cup holder and when I hit the bolt
fell somewhere.
Who knows where it flutes you.
But I knew I knew his shit.
Like I can't find that bull that's going
to get me in trouble,
just having a ball on my car.
So I looked for like two seconds,
Clinton find the ball and I just took
off running.
Um,
did you look at the other person in the
other car?
No,
I had no clue that it was a woman.
I had no clue that it was a pregnant
woman.
How much time are we talking about?
Like from the time was released,
from the time that I hit,
I had,
I was over a fence probably eight
seconds later.
It was,
it was literally a super reactionary,
like just,
I just felt I hadn't been home yet.
I stay at a friend's house.
I wasn't drinking and driving.
I,
you know,
my decision was to sleep at my friend's
house because I knew I couldn't drive
home.
He woke up early the next morning to go
to work and he's like,
John,
feel free to stay here.
And,
uh,
you know,
you can make yourself breakfast or
whatever,
whatever.
And I,
the guy has a family,
he has a wife and he has a newborn baby
and I didn't want to stay at his house
while he's at work,
so I was just like,
no,
I think I'm okay.
But really I had maybe like two hours of
sleep and,
um,
I didn't realize that I was still wasn't
ready to drive.
So,
um,
you know,
I wake up and get in my car and uh,
I just wasn't ready to drive or whatnot,
but,
um,
why didn't you look at the other car?
Because it all happened so fast.
Yeah,
sorry.
Yeah.
So it all happened so fast and,
um,
I just knew I was a,
I knew I smelled like alcohol and,
um,
I just felt like if the police came out,
it would be a bad situation for me.
And,
um,
I just thought the person that I hit had
to have been okay because I was totally
okay.
I was like,
maybe this collision wasn't that hard.
Um,
so I just feel like in a lot of people's
minds,
they see me as like,
ah,
I knew it was this woman.
I saw this woman hanging out the window
crying and bleeding or something like
that.
And like,
I just chose the lever and I didn't know
what I had it,
no,
if I hit a truck,
I didn't know if I hit a,
uh,
a punch bug,
I didn't know what it was that I hear
that just knows another vehicle.
B didn't even look,
no,
I didn't look wow.
And I didn't go back for cash,
but it doesn't make,
it doesn't make a what I did.
Okay.
The fact that,
you know,
I didn't go back for cash and I really
went back for my boy,
that's,
that's no better.
Right.
Um,
the whole situation was just a shitty
situation I was in.
I was in a really bad point in my life
taking,
like I said,
everything for granted.
If you wanted to have a,
a situation come up with just like worst
case scenario,
that is the worst case scenario,
pregnant woman.
Oh yeah.
It makes me lack of monster.
Yeah.
It makes me look a monster.
When you found out as a pregnant woman,
what was,
what was going through your mind?
The man,
I am,
I'm done.
First I was afraid that there will be
some type of,
uh,
problems with their baby because,
you know,
obviously if the,
if she had a difficult pregnancy,
then that's,
that's a whole different level of being
in trouble.
Um,
God forbid if she was having a
miscarriage,
um,
you know,
I would imagine that that would be 1000%
put on me.
So I thought about the fact that I went
from just partying and join this career
and this amazing fairytale life.
Um,
I went from,
I thought I was going from that to like
literally being in jail,
being labeled as a murderer.
So that was my,
that was my number one thing,
was just hoping that the baby was okay.
What about,
what were you thinking about yourself?
Like when you did that,
when you ran?
I mean,
there's no way you can be happy with
yourself that you did that.
What were you thinking?
Well,
I,
uh,
me and my mom have a great relationship.
I'm a mama's boy.
Um,
um,
and then I'm the father of four
daughters.
So,
um,
you know,
if anything,
my,
my respect for,
for women is I have tremendous respect
for a woman.
And I tried to like,
uh,
obviously that being a father I like,
I tried to,
I just felt like a monster.
I feel like a monster,
you know what I mean?
Um,
I just felt terrible.
I felt,
I felt really bad.
I was just,
I was mainly just concerned with this
woman's health and safety and I'm really
glad that she ended up being okay.
I felt really bad.
I was just like,
do it.
Even in the public side,
like you just heard a pregnant woman.
I'm like,
it doesn't really get worse than that,
but,
but yeah,
know I had no clue.
I had no clue that it was even a woman
that I hit and I felt terrible.
And what was the,
what was not just the,
what was the reaction from your family
and friends?
Um,
you know,
surprisingly it was,
it was okay.
You know,
um,
they,
they support me so much and they love me
so much and they know that,
you know,
that I haven't really,
uh,
I believe I have a good heart.
They know that I have a good heart.
Um,
and they were just,
they were just thinking,
man.
Like did anybody step in and say,
hey man,
you gotta get your shit together.
Oh,
I've had,
I've had a lot of people telling me I
need to get my shit together.
And what was it about?
Like what besides that,
what do you mean?
Like besides this one instance,
what other things have people come to
you and say,
Hey John,
you've got to get your shit together.
Um hmm.
Well,
of all of it,
everything that's happened over the last
two years or whatnot,
uh,
it makes people feel like they can tell
me that I need to get my shit together.
And I have recently,
I recently went outside to Mcguire's.
My garbage man was coming up and I was
late getting one of the garbage out to
the side of the road.
So he waited for me and he even told me,
he was like,
he was telling my garbage.
He's like,
hey man,
like I'm waiting to see you fight again.
He was like,
you really need to get it together.
I'm like,
man,
this dude is parked outside of my,
my little pretty boy.
He's telling me to get my shit together.
[inaudible] okay.